[Music]
we just had a good start to the year and
given the lineup we have a nothing short
of excited remember back when I made a
video on what I feel are the most
anticipated non-sequels this year a good
chunk of them happened to come from this
season that's right we're going to be
talking about a number of them in this
video and more so I can't wait to get
started so let's get going here are what
I think are the top 10 most anticipated
non-sequels for this spring season we
have my home hero for a very exciting
started
parents can be scary so what a way to
start the list right when salary man
tetsuo finds out that his daughter's got
physically abused by her boyfriend
matori is straight to the abyss for
matori however it turns out that only
complicates things as Matari has some
connections with The Syndicate and his
disappearance turns the vengeful Eyes Of
The Syndicate towards the enraged father
now tetsuo and his wife have to work
together in order to protect their
daughter it's an unexpected setup for a
thriller but it's one that will surely
take you through a very tense and
exciting experience when a single
mistake means Doom for the entire family
you won't find yourself bored with this
show with no shortage of adrenaline and
Stakes that only escalate with each
passing moment this has the potential to
be a sleeper hit of the season and if it
does end up becoming popular remember
you heard it here first
my home hero
um
[Music]
why raelina ended up at the Duke's
Mansion is our ninth most anticipated
title this spring
[Music]
now that title is a mouthful and in True
Light novel form it gives you a glimpse
of what to expect except this time it's
a manwa adaptation and it gives an
interesting twist to the usual
reincarnation stories that we've come to
expect you see we've come to expect
these reincarnated into Story characters
anime to be about the protagonist
playing the role of either the heroine
or the villain s but what if a girl this
time ends up being relegated to being a
novel's plot device a minor character
whose dead sets forth the entire story
no way she'll accept a fate like that
right with her eyes set on an
alternative timeline she seeks to use
her knowledge of future events and the
help of the Duke however things can't be
that easy especially if she has to use
one of the most two-faced characters in
the story can she overcome the volatile
Duke and find her happy ending we'll all
find out this spring in one of the more
interesting takes on The Reincarnation
stories that's been picking up some
steam
foreign
let me introduce you to the sponsors of
this video Immortal Rising yes it's time
to enter the Fantastical world of
immortal Rising which is the hottest
idle RPG in town let me tell you the
graphics in this game are something else
you'll be blown away by the unique and
Dark Fantasy characters monsters and
backgrounds it's like you've been
transported to another dimension where
magic and Mayhem reign supreme and the
action it's extreme stylish and so so
exciting get ready to unleash your
skills and defeat all kinds of evil
monsters with swords daggers bows and
Magic battles are fast paced so you'll
be leveling up in no time but here's the
best part the rewards you get everything
you need in this game gems enhanced
Stones room dice gold and loads more and
the progression is Limitless so whether
you're online or offline you'll be
raking in those rewards just by logging
in Daily it's like Christmas every day
and guess what you're not the only one
who's loving immortalizing with over 600
000 downloads worldwide this game is
most definitely a fan favorite so what
are you waiting for join the fun and
dive into Immortal Rising today by
clicking on the link in the description
next up is another show that I'm very
excited about dead Mound death play
[Music]
reincarnation tell this bring then
you're dead wrong dead Mount death play
takes The Reincarnation Trope and Spins
it backwards starring a necromancer
making his last stand as a last resort
in the climactic battle against a hero
he manages to escape Oblivion and
reincarnate into the real world a world
where magic is non-existent is a world
ripe for conquering after all what can
stop our protagonist now named polka
shinomia who retained his powers from
the previous life it turns out that
things might not be so easy in the real
world especially one where he finds
himself caught in the process of not
just the police but the bowels of the
underworld criminal gangs police
officers numerous political clashes
perhaps things might be too much even
for our ex Necromancer to handle if
you've been raring for these reverse
issakai titles dead Mount death play
could be your call this season it gives
me some Devil is a part-time arvives but
looking a lot darker and edgier in his
execution
oh
how about something sweet and wholesome
now with Skip and loafer
now there's a saying that goes the grass
is greener on the other side I'm sure
many of us feel that way especially
those living in small towns I mean
sometimes perhaps you find yourself
dreaming of the glamor and fun of being
in the big city well you're not alone as
mitsumi certainly feels the same way too
she wants nothing more than to move on
from a town enter a prestigious
University and make an impact on the
world however she gets slapped by
reality it turns out that City life is
more overwhelming than this naive
country girl thought it would be
thankfully help is on its way though as
she meets Shima a laid-back and overly
prepared boy who's pretty much her
perfect partner with his help will
mitsumi be able to overcome the
challenges of City Life and be the
change she wanted in the world there's
only one way to find out and that's by
tuning into this funny and heartwarming
tale set to hit the screens this spring
is
[Music]
foreign
I got a cheat skill in another world
[Applause]
huh
ever wondered what it's like getting all
those
Instagram bringing them back to the real
world that's definitely what a way to
you yatenjo bullied in his entire life
he wants nothing then to be able to
escape into a fantasy world that he can
have all the treasures and power his
heart desires the girls are just an
added bonus at this point but it gets
even better when he finds out that he
doesn't exactly have to say goodbye to
his old life either whatever he has in
the fantasy world can be brought back
and let's just say that the world will
never be prepared for the new and
improved yuya however living a double
life never comes without a catch as he
soon finds out how long will this double
life of his come biting and changing him
forever for good or for bad I got a
cheap skill and another world premieres
this spring and you're gonna have to
watch it to find out
we proceed with insomniacs after school
mama
anime just has a magical way of
connecting with the youth social anxiety
insomnia and the like seem to be themes
and growing pains that the youth just go
through these days where they say that
the grandest magic happens during those
Twilight hours where people seem to be a
lot more focused and attuned with the
world around them it's also a path to
closer bonds between two people sharing
the Dilemma like ganta and asaki can
attest the two complete opposites found
a mutual bonding Point trapped inside a
supposedly haunted astronomy club room
the two gear forced into interacting
with each other forming an unlikely
friendship they find a safe space in
each other's presence and the astronomy
club room that turns out to be the
location of their fated meeting the two
learn to grow through each other's help
and it will be quite a joy seeing the
two overcome their personal demons in
various setbacks insomniacs after school
comes this spring and after seeing what
the manga has to offer I can't wait for
this anime
foreign
if you're looking for a post-apocalyptic
world of Adventure Heavenly delusion
could be for you
[Music]
now that's a really engaging title Now
isn't it it's also a good summary of the
premise where we're treated to a world
where the youth are raised by robots
living inside a paradise the young ones
are protected from the outside world now
why would they need to be protected do
you ask well the outside is quite the
literal hellscape populated by
supernatural beings meanwhile our main
Duo Maru and kiruko Traverse that World
In Search Of Heaven so where is their
Journey going to lead them will it end
with salvation or Eternal wandering in
the post-apocalyptic world that used to
be Tokyo now one half is the basic
premise of the promised Neverland and on
the other perspective we have a brave
Adventure through an unknown World it
sounds very promising and if the
trailers are in thing to go by we've got
a sleeper hit on our hands this season
it's also a CNN series by production IG
so my expectations are pretty high for
this one for those who are raring for
one of those mature Adventure anime
filled with mysteries in a Sci-Fi
setting then don't miss this one
[Applause]
[Music]
Marshall kicks off our countdown to the
top three
Society has long taught us that going
against the norm spells discrimination
such a dilemma makes Mash burn Dead's
existence a perilous one in a world
dominated by Magic his magic list
presence warrants purging and that sends
him off to the woods in hiding there's
no coward and every day he spends time
training himself raising his skills to
be able to take on the strongest spell
Casters in the world with only his
physical strength now if he doesn't have
power he'll still Force Society to
acknowledge Him and that's by becoming
the Divine Visionary and the road to
that begins at Eastern magic academy one
of the most elite schools containing the
best and the brightest amongst the
world's aspiring magicians with such a
huge hurdle ahead Mash has his work cut
out for him will his training be enough
Everyone likes a lovable Underdog Story
and in a title that looks like he can
give some one punch man Vibes I'm sure
that a lot of us will have a good time
with this one Marshall's definitely one
of the shows to look out for
foreign
[Music]
s are a Wild Bunch they've got huge
Ambitions in getting close to their
ideal girls but I doubt that anyone can
have the privilege that Goro has with
regards to his favorite Idol I hoshino
being honored is an understatement when
you get to be the one to help her give
birth the poor doctor gets the chance of
a lifetime snapped Away by his untimely
death well so he thought so when he
opens his eyes he realizes instead of
simply just dying he'd become eyes
newborn child well it may seem like a
world of fun girl also learns more about
the ins and outs of the idol life the
Thorns that paved the path to Glory so
to speak fret not however bogoro will
make sure to protect his favorite Idol
smile even if he has to enlist theaters
some unlikely allies along the way
oshinoko finally gets its long-awaited
anime adaptation a fan favorite for a
very long time you'll get to see it hit
the screens this spring
[Music]
that
is
lastly our number one most anticipated
anime for spring is Hell's Paradise
[Applause]
betrayed and sentence for execution
death is all that awaits Gabi Maru the
hollow unfortunately he's someone who
just simply can't die and I mean it
literally luckily an immortal criminal
Looking For Freedom like him still has
some use is it south of Japan lies an
island which is said to contain the
elixir of life in exchange for his
freedom and full pardon by the shogunate
he has to retrieve the said treasure
even if he has to go through the gates
to the afterlife to do it together with
an expedition team Gabi Maru the hollow
prepares to embark on his perilous
Journey looking to return to his wife he
refuses to let any obstacle stand in his
way still given such an insanely huge
reward one has to wonder if this island
and the dangers that lie within can turn
out to be more than a match to the
immortal assassin and his ragtag team of
Misfits Thrills action Adventures a
group of characters that are easy to
root for hell's Paradise has it all as
long as we get a competent adaptation
this is easily going to be one of The
Season's biggest hits and with mop up on
the reins for this one I'm sure it's
going to be a banger
if you like what you've seen do check
out the channel for other videos that
you might like or keep in touch to the
various social media channels and don't
forget to check out Immortal Rising
through the link in the description and
experience the ultimate in Dark Fantasy
gaming thanks a lot for watching I'm
wishing you a great day ahead and hope
to see you again for the next video